"It is not in the stars to hold
our destiny, it is in
ourselves." Willy Shakespeare
said that, and he didn't know
quite how right he was.
The human body is made
up of over 200
different types of cells.
Each one of these is descended
from that first cell, the
zygote, that formed when the
genes of your dad teamed up
with the genes of your
mum to make you, you.
As you grew, these cells
multiplied and differentiated,
each one going down a different
developmental route.
And there was no
turning back--
their destiny was fixed.
It's like clay--
once it's been sculpted into
twee, ridiculous tat, it's
forever stuck that way.
In 2012, Shinya Yamanaka won
the Nobel Prize for working
out how you could manipulate our
genes, including the c-Myc
gene on chromosome 8,
and turn adult cells
back into stem cells.
These cells are full of
potential, and we can use them
to make any kind of
cell that we want.
Made from our own cells, one day
we may be able to regrow
organs, or repair them,
without any
fear of tissue rejection.
A great man once said, "You
cannot escape your destiny."
That one was Darth Vader.
But Luke Skywalker
and geneticists
have proved him wrong.